et maintenant si bernard tapie
pascal rambert
et mes fils de
bonsoir à tous
énorme ovation valable a dit
et ces comédiennes faut dire que c'est
un petit peu comme ça où tu es à tous
les soirs donc ça nous change pas
beaucoup
alors vous arrivez du théâtre du théâtre
de paris rue blanche où vous interpréter
un beau [ __ ] pour 100 représentations
exceptionnelles depuis le 30 janvier
alors c'est bourré c'est tous les soirs
bourré les gens se marrent ça va durer
plus de 100 représentations ben
apparemment on est parti pour cent
maintenant il est probable que si toutes
les conditions sont réunies pour que on
continue et que tout le monde puisse le
faire on se reverra sans représentation
exceptionnelle c'est du pipeau ouais
c'est très con me range pour appâter
légende en fin de compte peut-être vous
allez jouer là bas ça sans quoi alors
c'est une pièce de pierre chesnot mise
en scène par jean luc moreau ou linverse
mais bon non calais a été déjà joué par
jean luc moreau en acteur principal à la
place de bernard tapie avec des textes
additive de bernard tapie
vous avez rajouté des petits trucs aucun
auteur n'aurait ne retire en fait comme
je suis un beau [ __ ] on a ajouté aux
qualités de ce beau [ __ ] les miennes
mais en tout cas présumés tels ce qui
fait qu évidemment je deviens c'est à
hurler de rire
il ya un truc génial c'est quand il
arrive sur scène donc il dit vous savez
moi vous me connaissez je déteste le
mensonge et la brévine la salle et les
périls avec klose et de rien c'est pas
pourquoi il ya beaucoup d'autodérision
et vous avez donc enrichi le personnage
du départ qui en fait à un couvreur un
cours classique quoi un menteur mais là
vous avez fait un personnage plus plus
épais le bernard tapie telle qu'on que
les médias nous l'ont raconté pendant
des années non mais je crois qu'il est
il et il est de toute façon il est de
toute façon cynique et dans cet exercice
là il est de toute façon menteur et ce
qui est intéressant c'est que parmi les
1000 spectateurs qui appuient ce que ça
en contient à peu près on sent il y en a
forcément qui sont beaucoup plus menteur
que moi sur ce sujet là puisque trompent
leur femme pas moi donc c'est ça
127 fois depuis près de deux ans tiens à
dire que bernard tapie et alexandre
brousse depuis 32 ans et que l'on l'a
jamais trompé la mer bernard je crois
qu'on a un amant je ne crois pas capable
oui c'est ça une espèce de sale au
dragueur tchatcheur mais en fait qu'ils
se trouvent toujours une bonne excuse un
bon prétexte dans l'avion c'est comme
moi c'est ça a toujours raison vous
demandez aux femmes
chaque fois que le mec trompe sa femme
il commence par expliquer pendant des
heures pourquoi il le fait évidemment
c'est à cause d'elle elle ne comprend
pas il est malheureux albert mal enfin
il a toujours eu 1500 bonnes raisons
pour expliquer à la maîtresse qui est
pas dû voilà pourquoi je compte pas
sinon je l'aurais jamais trompé bien
attendez voilà c'est ça l'histoire
en tous les cas vous fait le clown et
vous avez l'air d'aimer ça les gens
adorent ça donc tout va bien
oui mais on revient en enfance c'est ça
la fin la vertu de l'acteur c'est d'être
en enfance je vous donne un exemple
pendant les répétitions n'a pas nos
objets la vallée b et on sent la vente
alors si l'objet choisi pour être un
revolver c'est un cendrier et bien le
troisième jour quand on commence à
répéter où il est mort évolué il s'agit
de retrouver cendrier qu'il devient le
revolver et si j'avais la paille n'est
pas question de changer par autre chose
donc cette espèce de facultés de
redevenir enfant et de jouer comme on
joue et quand on est gosse qu'on fait le
chauffeur d'autocar a fait semblant
nettement à contrôler mais c'est sympa
qui joue au docteur louis bailly paf
c'est pareil tu te souviens tu as joué
au docteur on faisait des terminait-il
jouer connaît la température je fais
partie de mettre 500 diplômés
non mais à la fin de la piège quand je
dis vous prenez du plaisir mais bon on
dirait de funès comme motorola ou fait
des grimaces vous tournez sur vous même
c'est insensé
écoutez c'est vraiment venu au fur et à
mesure que la pièce le suscitait cas de
nature on a tous une dose de pudeur qui
vous empêche de faire à certains c'est
son geste
quand même pas courir avec la valise à
la main en fait maintenant choteau tu
l'état j'ai vu très beaux sauts
d'ailleurs parce que c'est ça le vrai
truc révolte -faisant fort alors voilà
donc le beau [ __ ] change de femme tous
les dix ans donc il ya quatre femmes
autour de lui à vous d'abord pascal
robert ce qui avait été sa première
femme inconditionnels haleine mais voilà
mais elle adore sa maman c'est sa maman
sabam enfin bon ils ont pimenté la
classe
moi je connais l'âge de pascale roberts
et franchement vous êtes super en forme
vraiment voilà donc vous vous êtes la
première femme c'est dans la lah depuis
20 ans et avec vous chers agnès soral a
buzzé marié 12 l'épousé officielle la
femme
moi je suis voilà merci ciel l'officiel
natacha plus est la maîtresse dépressif
alcoolique extraordinaire très bien
gaulée je dois dire parce qu'il faut
dire dans cette caisse est que quand
même un des grands plaisirs de la pièce
puis rejoue un poil elle est très
dévêtues
avec une devise est parce qu elles ont
alors tout le monde fait ça pour voir
votre club vous savez quand même et la
voiture parce qu'elles n'ont même pas
alors une à moi j'arrive pas à la voir
c'est un fou rire voilà d'achat vous
êtes la maîtresse depuis dix ans 1
et puis voilà et puis le beau [ __ ]
bernard tapie vous quitte pour vous
mathilde penin dont vous êtes la petite
découverte apic nouvelles comme ça sur
laquelle il est très très chaud et quand
on vous voit en comprend et il est prêt
à partir avec elle donc ce que je disais
c'est quand la pièce commence le beau
[ __ ] s'apprête à tout plaquer les
trois femmes qui sont là pour vous pour
partir en australie avec vous le
problème c'est que c'est son
anniversaire il a 55 ans voilà sept
jours et s est bien choisi pour ces
bateaux en fait le vrai truc c'est que
je dois me tirer en douce et mais il ya
chez moi ma valise avec tous mes pape la
voilà et donc je dis à ma fiancée julie
et coutumes attend on se retrouve à
l'aéroport je vais chercher la valise
évidemment je donne un coup de fil à ma
femme pour lui dire d'aller se coucher
je peux pas rentrer et elle m'apprend
que c'est l'anniversaire qui a une
grande faim voilà voilà le problème
c'est que j'arrive à tirer la valise au
moment où il ya une fête géante l'art la
voilà est donc évidemment problème alors
l'homme c'est malin en plus c'est que
chaque génération de fans dans la salle
se retrouve dans le gym de vous casser
la houle sur le plan marketing c'est
béton armé parce que évidemment tout le
monde se reconnaît les hommes se
reconnaissent dans le personnage du du
beau [ __ ] son vous en faites pas ce
que vous finalement comme on l'a dit ça
fait 32 ans que vous êtes avec votre
épouse et vous ne l'avez jamais trompé
c'est dû à quoi elle
ab c'est normal dans un couple ira
toujours pour que ça dure faut qu'un
accueil s'aérer elle c'est dû à quoi
c'est dû au fait que secret sexuelle
berlin c'est en tout cas ça peut pas
être ça ne peut pas être l'élément qui
m'aurait fait partir non je crois qu'il
ya d'abord une volonté que ça dure parce
que chaque couple a des moments de crise
forcément et ces moments de crise où on
est sûrement très bien on dit bon allez
on essaie quand même ou bien et c'est
tout à fait légitime dans certains
tapent durement laisse aller et on dit
autre chose
ensuite il ya les activités
professionnelles qui joue un rôle si on
a 80 % de son temps actif
résolument tourné sur son âtre sur son
travail sur ce que l'on fait on
connaissait qu'on a moins de temps ni
savourer ça vous dit si j'avais pas
tendre ces jeux la tête trompait si
jamais rien eu à [ __ ] de la ville
d'hiver par jour a rien à faire je
l'aurais fait ensuite il ya aussi quelle
est l'évolution dans le temps des deux
personnages
il ya des gens qui évolue d'une manière
ou d'une autre mais en tout cas rarement
de la même manière et là je crois qu'on
ait eu à peu près la chance d'évoluer
part eyal maintenant bernard à l'âge que
vous avez ya plus tellement présent vous
l'a trompée elle a même plus aucune
est ce que vous croyez que les femmes
ont plus à gagner en étant féminine que
féministe féminine on a posé la question
à bernard
alors moi je répondrai
non franchement je répondrais sa défense
ça dépend de l'heure de la journée
alors la pièce s'appelle un beau [ __ ]
voulu trouver beau parce que ça nous ça
s'est fait ah les [ __ ] c'est admis
ebuya le maquillage
ouais le soir il ya un gros vous avez
pas mal bernard c'est vrai j'ai pas un
cheveu blanc maintenant il est bien à
mes cheveux
ah bah oui je vais pas bah sinon il
serait soit patrouilles et des mecs chez
qui ce sera énorme
non parce qu'il y en a trop rires cela
il ya un moment quand c'est quelqu'un
que j'ai laissé moment le plus dur c'est
ni blanc ni gris ouais alors ça c'est un
peu dégueulasse
moi ce que j'aime bien
oui ça lui va bien parce que tout lui va
bah c'est gentil mais qui est pas une
chose avant d'être blanchi oui mais ça
ne marche pas parce que bondy 3 les
filles qu'est ce qu'il a de plus
séduisant lui d'avoir tapis moi je
dirais cela naturel ouais moi j'aime ça
il y il est dir est une nature
sa pêche à le fait qu'ils se laisse pas
démonter
c'est plutôt une espèce de fragilité qui
se voit certains qu'ils décèlent à
certains moments et et où vraiment je
trouve qu'il a l'air d'un enfant
voudrait qu'il a une virilité évident
une viralité les vies normales as tu le
sais a réglé la vue de presse
et on m a dit qu est-ce que sa femme a
depuis ce que vous voulez pas être tous
tes qualités réunies à je pense que
c'est une femme qui est qui qui devait à
ses multiples oui elle a encore bien
anglais en ont le retenir oui à l'intrus
la boîte à lettres une gamine et de
timidité elle est très jolie
levine elle doit être très intelligent
c'est parce qu'elle sait faire clc
cercle à elle laisse aller mais voilà
quoi ouais foutais ou qu'on le tient par
les couilles j'ai l'impression aussi
vous fassiez quoi pascal de lui avant de
le connaître
moi il m'a toujours fasciné par cette
espèce de sympathie qui peut qu'il
dégage et même je le trouve formidable
dit quelque chose on n'y croit pas ça je
trouve ça formidable
c'est le problème
alors pensez quoi avant de le connaître
je l'avais rencontrée sur le lellouche
ah oui et j'avais donc je connaissais
d'avant et je l'avais vu jeu
bon il faisait rêver à l'époque je sais
pas à la manière dont il a été porté
comme ça au sommet je me disais c'est
bien ça fait rêver
jeudi un bond à priori oui vous aussi
natacha excellent parce que j'avais
gardé de lui certaines images des
missions dans dans lesquelles il avait
brillé dans par le passé comme par
exemple le débat le pen avec le pen
alors que ça c'était quelque chose qui
m'avait vraiment marqué va-t-il vous
pensiez quoi de tapis avant de le
rencontrer
je pensais que c'était quelqu'un qui
savait tout faire ce qu'on a et comme
image et pour l'instant c'est ce que je
pense que j'aurai comme comme comédien
il a des progrès à faire comme comédien
du sauveur fâcheux n'arriverait pas le
tout à l'heure tout à l'heure on était
dans la loge agnès m'a donné une
indication bien parce qu'à ce moment là
fait plus haut ça je vais faire mais
c'est vrai parce que on se voit pas mais
ce qu'on entend c'est la réaction des
gens et là on voit bien mois y avait un
truc que je voulais pas faire vous
donnez à venir et il y avait un moment
où je servais un alcool à une
psychanalyse et la caisse raconte pas le
coup non ma parole mais je dis
simplement ce moment là il me faisait
pas marrer et j'étais gêné de le faire
le soumet à manger à chaque fois le gp
je vais faire ça j'étais gêné car ça je
me régale maintenant si vous l'avez vu
ses amours et il nous en fait un maximum
mais c'est drôle c'est à mourir et les
gens le réclament mais ça donne ça donne
pas envie d'y aller
rigoler et a peur d'être re baffie
donner du bonheur pendant des mois et
manquera pas de la vie privée en soirée
thurman ton public qui applaudit à
chaque vanne pas moi ça dessert
je vous demande de visa
voilà voilà voilà
ian hacking a finalement cette pièce
était fait pour vous parce que j'ai
retrouvé une déclaration de vous 113 90
aph
non j'ai retrouvé une déclaration de
vous lors du procès om valenciennes et
vous avez déclaré j'ai menti mais
c'était de bonne foi ouais bah là c'est
ça dans la piastre
si vous me demandez leur et je vous dis
il est 16h cibafi vous demande l'heure
et que vous lui lie 16 heures alors qu
il était 17 heures vous avez menti de
bonne foi c'est sa matière de bonne foi
oui elle est à lire vous dit quelque
chose qui est une erreur ou est une
fausse information vous l'a dit de bonne
foi alors que la dent dans ce qu'on joue
je suis de mauvaise foi et jeudi une
information fausse ou sachant qu'elle
est fausse mais voilà les voilà c'est du
théâtre c'est depuis la braise ici c'est
voila voila c'est la commune
c'est très chouette alors on veut bien
croire à couper au montage on veut bien
croire que vous ayez jamais menti à
votre à votre femme
mais vous avez menti à d'autres gens
dans votre vie quelle est la plus belle
promesse que vous ayez faite par exemple
à vos parents sans l'avoir tenue je vais
pas mentir mais pas ouais c'est pas par
vertu c'est parce que ça s'est pas
présentée et je verrai alors je n'ai pas
eu l'occasion quoi bah voilà et oui
alors c'est bien quand je parle un
deschamps j'ai l'impression d'être le
seul moteur du monde
sous-entendu vous montez pas
personnellement ça ce sera coupée au
montage
bernard ça veut dire menti bernard
quelle est la plus belle promesse que
vous ayez faite aux français quand vous
étiez ministre sans l'avoir tenue je
vous dire d'abord celle que j'ai fait
est que j'ai tenus parce que c'est là on
n'a jamais tenu rigueur et je suis
content que natasha est était est été
marqué par ce débat j'avais dit à cette
occasion la conçurent su rentrer en
politique je mettrai le pen à moins de
10% est la seule élection nationale à
laquelle j'ai participé c'était les
élections européennes où le pen a fait 9
moi j'ai fait très 14-13 gaye donc je
suis content d'avoir tenu cet engagement
là et celui-là il valait quelque chose
qui tient les engagements merci cartes
de bons clients alors les engagements
les engagements de jeunes y parvenir
c'est tout ce que j'ai promis aux deux
ministres ouais pour une raison simple
c'est que le temps de réaction de ce que
l'on dit par rapport à l'action c'est au
moins trois ans j'étais ministre un an
ouais donc voilà voilà là il n'y a rien
de tenue alors les promesses que vous
avez pas tenu vis-à-vis de vos employés
aucune parce que les employés devenait
les employés définitif que lorsque le
ménage avait malheureusement été fait
ouais qui demande la carte mais non mais
attends vous êtes vous découvrez
aujourd'hui les les horreurs des
licenciements sous-entendu il ya des
gens qui quand il se trouve dans une
structure qui marchent pas peuvent
licencier au nom de l'impératif besoin
de sauver l'entreprise et y en a
d'autres pour qui sait des bouchers
charcutiers chaque fois qu il y 16 ans y
ait quelqu'un c'était presque un bonheur
ou un plaisir de le faire alors moi je
sais pas faire je vous donner deux
exemples concrets où elle fut pas cette
question
quand je reprends adidas adidas faire à
peu près deux milliards par an le
concurrent principal c'est nike qui
gagne 2 milliards par an pourquoi ils
sont plus intelligents ils sont vos
goûts nike travail avec 7000 employés
tous ces enfants chinois ou taïwanais
tous nous ont travaillé douze mille
employés tous se repaît points c'est
plus cher
deux hypothèses vous laisser comme ça et
adidas est mort c'est possible
vous avez la charge de l'arbre et c est
vous laverez c'est dans ce sens qui a
été fait à dire des fermetures d'usinés
qu'ont coûté quatre ou cinq mille
emplois sur 12 comprends moi que les
4000 qui ont perdu leur boulot sur les
12000 à cause de moi considère que je
suis le roi des [ __ ] parce que quand
vous leur expliquer que c'est pour
sauver l'entreprise ils s'en foutent ils
ont perdu leur boulot
pour certains il ne retrouve pas avant
trois quatre ans mais c'est comme ça je
veux dire que c'est un métier qui est ok
tu arrives j'aurais préféré rester toute
ma vie d'artiste
barret malheureusement j'ai pas eu j'ai
pas eu l'intelligence de dire oui à la
louche quand j'avais 25 ans c'est vrai
franchement je vous assure vraiment
jeune à l'époque oui
non mais c'est dans l'aventuré que je
regrette parce que je trouve dans ce
métier tout ce que j'aime
il n'y a rien de ce que je n'aime pas
donc vous regrettez pas avoir commencé
plutôt être comédien ah oui vraiment
j'aurais pas affronter toutes ces merdes
la carte alors quelle est la promesse
que vous aviez fait un juge
et vous n'êtes pas tenu au ils ont pas
eu besoin de promesses
ouais bah ils m'ont largement way est ou
non traité aux supporteurs de l'om qui
est la promesse que vous leur avez fait
est que ce n'est pas gagné la coupe
d'europe on l'a gagné ouais mais il ya
bien que vous avez pas tenu quand même à
laquelle je sais pas je vous demande de
normand et à mitterrand il ya des
promesses que vous lui avez fait et je
n'ai pas de pauvres malheureux non non
je sais pas je me renseigne la nuit tu
es vachement vos promesses vertes
lapinou way mine de rien bah oui mais
pourquoi bieber ndash c'est pas ben non
c'est pourquoi mine de rien c'est pas
mine de rien c'est oui il me débecte
vous êtes vraiment un mec incroyable
vous avez été le chanteur d'abord
l'argent mais à l'époque où j'étais
étudiant et donc j'étais pas chiante à
jouer les paroles de la chanson c'était
désaccord il ya toute une philosophie
qui étaient contenues dans cette chanson
les paroles de la chanson ces croyants
mais peu importe mes paroles souvent je
dis n'importe quoi si mes idées sont un
peu folle vrai ou faux ne t'en fais pas
c'est bien oui c'est toute une
philosophie mais attention et 1966 alors
s'il fallait vrai la philosophie des
paroles des chansons de son père était
pas tout le monde
excuse moi je peux t'en donner notre
réussir sa vie car il sait très bien
réussir sa vie
ah oui
c'était le contraire de réussir dans la
vie donc on peut tirer une phrase de
tout un palmarès pour démontrer qu'un
mec et sotchi où cela alors vous avez
été chanteur dont home d'annuaires homme
d'affaires oui est ce que c'est vrai
d'un repas pique avec toutes les
entreprises que vous avez racheté pour 1
franc symbolique vous auriez pu vous
payer un paquet de clopes
non mais le franc symbolique c'est
pareil c'est une image des vivres en
personne vous donne son entreprise pour
1 franc 1 6 braquer des mecs à ces cons
on arrivait une voirie les fusils
mitrailleurs on les mettait sur la tête
est bon plus bohème pas ben watt pour 1
franc
donc c'est qu'il y avait peut-être
autour un certain de choses joe qui
vendait un franc mais ils ont des dettes
avait gelé les terrains voilà de tous
les boulots vous avez fait c'est lequel
qui rapporte le plus en argent ouais
évidemment chef d'entreprise quand ça
marche
évidemment aujourd'hui salah
financièrement parce que vous verrez du
modèle sont gelés battre être élu par le
fiston médicaux c'est jusqu'au 18 mars
et tranquille un 18 mars une énorme
on va voir la fête et on va voir et de
toucher un gros paquet là bernard a tout
récupéré fois j'en tue il ya un milliard
d'euros il ya vraiment ça vous emmerde
que je récupère non pas du tout alors là
pas du tout mais franchement même
franchement non mais tu vois ça dans le
dans le sujet qui veut racheter
et quand il va récupérer les sous qui
fera un chèque kwassa clowns sans
frontières
si j'ai beaucoup d'argent il en est
aperçu de membres et à ma fille de faire
un film
mais moi aussi je peux payer à perdre et
on a marqué on va faire on va faire des
ajouts les gens qui sont là on vit mon
film donc la tomate celles qui veulent
enlever ou alors il ya plus 7 sur 7
bernard vous ne manquez beaucoup de sous
moi j'aime bien quand c'est 25 l'air
avec le pull en mohair anny blatt le
gros mont blanc et vous allez l'avoir le
dimanche soir c'est un vrai bonheur pour
moi il est voué bruel c'était
sympathique cette source
ouais le sol qui a dit des choses pas
gentilles c'était moi quand même mais
elle avait un peu taquiné je l'avais un
peu taquiné sur sa montre cartier
ah oui j'oubliais la vente quartier il y
avait le mont blanc le but là ni bla du
biais de mon quartier
alors dites moi on a envie d'avoir dans
bernard un an
on a envie d'avoir votre avis sur ce qui
se passe
l'histoire de juppé par exemple en
pensez quoi juppé qui se fait condamner
par les juges
et puis le présent la public qui dit que
c'est un type formidable c'est pas la
première fois qu'il dit oui les
magistrats sont maintenant vraiment
devenu indépendant hier aucun doute là
dessus
aucun et par conséquent tous les
éléments qui leur donnent l'impression
qu'on leur force la main ou qu'on veut
les pousser dans un système qui dépasse
le cadre précis la loi ils deviennent
féroce moi même je vais payer par a fait
le con comme ça en pensant aussi que
l'on pouvait faire le malin ou ça sert à
rien vraiment et la faire dans la sphère
c'est les magistrats qui ont subi des
menaces qui ont eu leurs bureaux visités
vous pensez que c'est possible ça avoue
non non non non non mais je n'adore pas
ce qui était dit non les yeux dans les
yeux je me suis dit mais vous y croyez
vous moi je vous dis je sais pas non
pourquoi pas la virée des trains alors
qu'ils aient déjà eu des gens qui
essayent de tirer le jugement avant le
jugement
ça c'est plutôt dans votre boulot qu'il
faut trouver les gens capables de faire
ça dans les milieux politiques dans les
milieux politiques
ça va rien changer y prennent le
jugement ils savent qu'il existe et
qu'il est bon donc c'est pas c'est pas
ça je ne dis pas qu'il ya pas eu de
trucs mais ça peut pas être le fait des
gens concernés directement par ce procès
ça c'est sûr et vous trompez pas si les
politiques aujourd'hui bourg là dessus
pour dire on veut savoir ce qui s'est
passé c'est qu'ils sont enfin que vous
voyez
arrivé le loup c'est pour arriver à dire
mais la décision n'a pas été prise
sereinement
vous avez compris pourquoi ils foncent
tout cela qu'un et pour voir l'âge que
vous fassiez pas un petit peu de
commentaires politiques de temps en
temps comme ça à la télévision oui juste
histoire de rigoler et pas parce que
vous connaissez bien les trucs abbaoui
dindar d'écart ah ben oui un peu dites
moi alors le pen en paca
j'y croyais pas une seconde non ah ouais
penser que c'est encore un épouvantail
qu on nous agite non non non non non non
ma dernière fois non non non ce qui
c'est un vrai danger
et puis alors je vous signale que tout
ou toute attitude qui consisterait à
dire non non qu'on fait rien ce serait
criminel et j'y crois pas franchement
j'y crois pas et je pense que muselier
va le battre
ah oui c'est d'ailleurs parce que vous
êtes plus pote avec muselier bouquet ump
frères terre avant ou plus qu'avec
vauzelle est beaucoup plus et
socialistes pas parce que j'ai fait
beaucoup à vauzelles qui lui m'a
beaucoup fait chier alors que j'ai rien
fait à muselier qu'elle est sympa avec
moi et voilà à quoi ça tient
donc moi je m'en fous le reste ça n'a
pas d'intérêt mais la base est là il est
comme ça oui il est un peu comme ça tu
peux compter sur lui quand tu as besoin
de rien alors tu es mon soulier
je vais bien ma marraine bistrot avec
lui on n'a pas bien physique
sarkozy président en tout cas c'est
quand même pas une hypothèse dénuées de
tout fondement
apparemment quand on voit les sondages
ça a l'air d'être bien parti pour lui
enfin j'ai l'impression au mois d'août
et vous sarkozy je n'ai pas de ce bord
là dois je regarde ça avec mes enfin
d'après ce que voit il ya déjà des
sondages qui ont l'air de le placer très
largement devant tout le monde
ça vous le savez vous le craignez
sarkozy faisait peur qu'une fois au
pouvoir ils tiennent un petit peu trop
autoritaire il ya personne qui peut
devenir troupe korité dans ce pays qui
est ingérable
ouais hein ah oui bien sûr on veut tout
changer toujours médaille vous bougez un
truc tout le monde gueule ouais faire le
malin personne peut être autoritaire en
fait un peu comme ça répond pas
longtemps c'est comme avec les gosses de
maintenant voilà yapi yapi de papa et
maman autoritaire y en a mais bon cela
ils sont vite remis par le juge du coin
bien dans dix mois alors on va terminer
sur votre âge parce que dans la pièce de
nous raconter pendant toute la soirée
mais oui je suis en 43 matchs par
exemple vous avez quoi pour rester
conserver comme ça se fait en quelques
belles poses et baghriche d'abord comme
un fou moi je vois pas ça ce serait un
match à wimby vais pas vous filmez je ne
boit pas une goutte d'alcool je sais ce
qu'elle n'y paraît et je fais un tout
petit peu l'amour ça fatigue des
permanences à saisir prématurément s'il
va le savoir
coté à 2 balles
camus
agnès soral l'atacama
la ville de fès
messieurs à vous en scène de jean luc
laurent